hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I wanted to give eight
things that you should really consider
doing if you are completely flat broke I
know what it's like to be broke now
fortunately my business is build up I've
got a successful property portfolio but
honestly there's been times in my life
when I've been so I would say poor
because I think the definition of poor
is when you don't have money you're
never gonna have many years of poor
person broke is when you just haven't
got any cash right now you are skipped
and I've been there man believe me I've
been there I remember one time when I
was so broke that I was driving and I
had no petrol and I went to try and get
petrol and I didn't have enough money to
get petrol so I thought well if I just
bought five pounds in that way I'll be
able to just drive home and then figure
a way to get some more money I didn't
even have five pounds my card wouldn't
accept you I was so badly overdrawn like
to phone my little sister and ask you to
transfer just a few pounds to me just so
I could then get some petrol to get back
home so I really do understand the pain
that what it's like being poor broke
skin whatever you want to call it I
teach people how to get rich I don't
think people how to become financially
free but I get a lot of people sometimes
that come to me that literally are skins
no money at all and this video is for
people that are in that situation the
most a people like that because that's
not who you are that's not your destiny
that's not your identity that's your
current situation
number one is never ever ever go into
debt to pay for bills that's like the
worst thing ever it's a downward spiral
because if you borrow money to pay money
that you owe then what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have to pay that back plus
next month you've got the same bills
again so it's a downward downward spiral
it is just the worst thing you can do
and it's gonna mean that you're gonna be
in the same situation you're in right
now but just for much worse for much
longer now this might confuse some
people because I do talk about debt as a
good thing he doesn't think debt is a
good thing if you're borrowing money to
invest it and the profits that you're
making off of the investments is gonna
be able to pay back the debt and more
then it's like really good but right now
you're probably in that place you're
probably thinking about getting money to
pay off bills don't do it ever ever ever
number two is never bury your head in
the sand it's so tempting when you've
got no money and the situations really
bad
just avoid even looking into the
situation because you think think what
even worse than I think and what people
do and I've done this is use very heavy
sand and think it's really bad if I just
bury my head in the sand maybe it'll
just get better and then things will
just get better in time that's a really
bad thing to do because you cannot get
to where you need to be without first
acknowledging where you are
so as depressing as it is you need to
just figure out how much money do you
owe what are your expenses what are your
incomings and work out exactly where you
are and advise yourself as if advising a
best friend you see here's the thing
you've probably had situations where
your friends have been in bad situations
and you're able to come in as a third
party look into the situation help them
out look just advise yourself as if you
are your best friend because you know
what you kind of are
number three is never let friends or
family come to you and ask you to pay
their bills for them we're now
financially stuck as hard as it is to
see your loved ones struggling you
cannot let them depend on you until you
can become financially stable yourself
now you may feel that you're helping
them out and people say to me all the
time look you know I give money but I'm
helping them out and I'll say well how's
it going because at the moment you don't
really helping anyone
they're always skin you're always skin
it's not working
you might mean well but I tell you
something those people that come to you
and ask you for money
they are only asking you because you are
the easiest option if you say no because
you need to get yourself sorted they
will find a way you're not helping them
anyway what you're doing is you're
actually training them to become
dependent which is never a good thing
for you for them or for anybody so
please please please if you're skint if
you're broke your absolute struck one
Anjali don't give money away just
because people ask you and you feel bad
number four is find ways to reduce your
monthly expenses now you might think
this is impossible but here's the thing
I want you to log on to your bank
statement go online and look at all the
standing orders all the direct debits
that are leaving your account every
single month and just go through them
with a fine-tooth comb and work out
which ones you can live without which
ones you can count so maybe there's
someone that you don't even know what
they are you could be paying for a gym
membership and you don't even know
because you've been burying your head in
the sand for too long so cancel all the
expenses that you don't need shrink them
as low as possible even if this is the
case of just stepping one step back in
the future to take two steps forward and
some of your expenses might be paying
interest payments for deaths if you'll
pay really high interest rates on loans
and debts and credit cards ring up the
company speak to them and see if you can
reduce the interest rates and see what
you can negotiate really important to
save money as well as make money number
5 is focus on the solution not the
problem you see the problem is that
you're in debt and you're broke but the
solution is that you need to make more
money the thing that you focus on the
most is the thing that would expand so
if you spend all your time saying I'm
broke I'm broke I'm broke
thinking about how much of a failure you
are then that's going to manifest and
you're gonna more debt more brokeness is
going to come into your life whereas if
you focus on the solution which is
actually making more money then that's
what's going to happen so how do you get
more money well the first thing I'll say
the best thing to do is to become very
valuable in your job and if you're not
working in if you're not in your job
just go get a job even if the job is not
what you want to do the long term set
your dream job go get a job once you've
got a job become valuable find ways to
become as valuable as possible
as you can to your to your workplace and
then when you'll become more valuable
don't be afraid to ask for a pay rise
number six is manage your money manage
the little money that you have you might
be broke but you've still got some money
the Bible says that when you're faithful
with a little then you'll be given a lot
some people that say I need more money I
need more money I need more money they
don't need more money they can't they
couldn't even handle more money lottery
winners tend to go broke again so maybe
your problems not just that you need
more money maybe you need to manage the
little money that you've got well I
haven't got any money how can I manage
it well when you get paid whatever money
you get paid may be the first of the
month or whatever it is don't spend it
all at once
allocate it properly put a percentage
aside for bills a percentage aside of
paying off your debts a percentage aside
and just splitting up manage what you've
got because honestly everybody that's
broke they're the most broke just before
they get paid on payday and the reason
that is is because they have mismanaged
their money throughout the month so
manage them when they get to grips with
your finances and when you're faithful
with the little that you have I promise
more is going to come into your life
number seven that's eight seven share
your burdens with other people speak to
people about your situation now what I
don't mean by this is I don't me become
a bitching whining moaning broke person
that asks everybody for money that
becomes a thorn in everybody else's side
not at all but what I do mean is
sometimes when you just share a problem
it's a problem halved and the worst
thing ever is being broke but also being
misunderstood and feeling alone and
isolated so speak to people that you
trust and not in a negative way not in a
moaning whining way but just today how
do you think I can get better at this
can you give me some advice you know be
coachable speak about this freely and
openly don't be ashamed because I tell
you something you're not on your own and
pretty much every single millionaire and
even billionaire that there is today has
been really really broke at some point
it's not your it's not your destination
it's not your identity it's just your
circumstances right now and there's
nothing wrong with talking about that
and lastly and possibly most importantly
number eight is educate yourself and put
a plan in place now at school don't
teach anything about
in finances so there's no wonder that
there's so many millions and millions of
people in the UK and across the world
that have no money but what I'll say is
start educating yourself about money
because you will never become
financially free if you continue doing
the same things that you're doing now
the things that you've been doing have
gotten to this point where you are now
so now you won't start doing different
things but you can only do different
things if you learn different ways of
life and if you learn around money
property investments management you need
to learn these skills when I was 17
years old I remember being so broke but
still I was going into an overdraft I
couldn't pay the petrol I was getting
into my overdraft to learn about
property to learn about investments why
would I do that when I was so broke well
while I let the friends they were going
to university they were spending nine
thousand pound a year going to
university to get student debt so why
wouldn't I invest everything I've
possibly got and more to invest in
myself you are your best investment now
am I saying that you should take out
thousands and thousands of pounds in
more loans and more debts to become
educated well absolutely not not
necessarily maybe I'll be the right
thing to do but what I am saying is
start spending your time and your
resources getting freedom information
now over an a 2-day property investors
crash course I would suggest even if
you're broke and you have no money to
invest I would say come along we do more
advanced training programs that are
pretty big hefty investments should you
do that I don't know maybe maybe not but
start educating yourself in the best way
that you can reading books attending
seminars speaking to the right kind of
people getting rid of your friends who
are May sayers and you don't want the
best for you and hanging around people
that want you to be the best you you can
be that are making good money and that
will support you in your journey so
that's kind of the gist of the eight
things that I would suggest that you do
I hope you enjoyed that listen I make
these videos the reason I made this
video is because I really genuinely want
to see people do well in my life I want
to see people for I'm actually free I
want to see people succeed so I want to
send me a message today just saying my
situation is really bad I've got no
moaning I'm absolutely broke and I
thought man how can I help it so I sat
down and a red little plant I sent it to
her over messenger and then I just
thought well I
I've spent the time doing it anyway why
not make a video and share the same
eight points with you guys for anyone
else who's struggling so I hope you
found the video beneficial please do
smash the like button if you enjoyed
this content also if you're not
subscribe up the channel subscribe down
below turn on the notification bell if
you want to see a video where I started
all over again from scratch with
absolutely no money and became
financially free in one week you can do
the same - maybe not straight away maybe
you need to learn first but if you want
inspiration and you want to watch me do
that you can check out that video right
here if you want to come to the property
investors crash course and learn the
skills then you can get a free ticket
right here so you can get your free
tickets the property investors crash
course and of course please don't forget
subscribe which you can do over here
thanks so much for watching and I'll see
you real soon
your future is bright